[Laughter]
speaking again pegged nice yeah pump for
this yeah no man this was this was the
hardest I've laughed at a at a
relationship advice post oh I love these
it's just it's crazy how I just happen
to go and read it every once in a while
and just find the best [ __ ] let's see
what is it um I 15 male got a boner when
my mom 42 male sat on me when we were
moving what throw away because Oedipus
okay me throw away account this username
is no incest okay oh my god
now before I read this I'm for sure like
this is a troll okay I damn it there's
one replying here that had me dying so
he goes my family moved a week ago and
my mom had to sit on my lap in the car
because there was no more room and my
brother was sitting in the front she
moved around a little and I started to
get a boner I was yelling in my head no
but I couldn't stop it no so I rode all
the way there well buddy I think she
wrote all the way there yeah nice with a
boner I don't think my mom noticed which
just made me think like this gets more
Oedipus why I don't think my mom noticed
cuz her ass is huge and there's no lack
of penetration she's got a super big hot
ass there's no way I could penetrate her
gigantic big beautiful now let me
describe my mom's ass for a second she's
got some [ __ ] cake alright alright
and I'm proud to be from that cake yeah
so when she was throwing it back on me
in the car yeah um I eat it all in my
pant but I I don't think my mom noticed
but I'm worried I might be attracted to
her
now I'm hyper aware of how I look at her
I make sure I'm not looking at her chest
or butt or her or her big guard gamesman
she is or beautiful supple melons her
big sexy ass cheeks or I don't know how
to feel about my mom's hot that's a
[ __ ] that's why that's a porn title
yeah from
other [ __ ] account you were talking
about before no what was one what kind
of [ __ ] is this oh yeah yeah yeah
yeah how do i how to feel about my mom
sexy ass I came on my mom's big ass
titties how should I feel about my mom's
sweet [ __ ] butt cheeks
sometimes when I'm watching porn she
crosses my mind and I immediately know I
don't know what to do I don't want to be
attracted to my okay
so oh man so there was there's a lot of
good replies right the first one was
like you're 15 brushing against the
couch will get you a boner let alone
having a person sit on you it's nothing
along the Oedipus line rub one out and
like forget about it so a lot of people
were in there being like dude you're
young you're gonna get boners like it
doesn't matter yeah yeah all right this
is my second to the best favorite okay I
like how you added your mom's age and
gender as if that might change things
like my mom 46 yeah
like if she yeah 40 15 male yeah like if
she was 44 he go well that's fine oh oh
oh I thought she was a she's 46 then
it'd be [ __ ] weird then it'll be
weird but 44 oh wait you're 16 oh dude
mom I don't want to be turned on by my
mom or her sweet [ __ ] but I love my
mom's hot hello my love my mom's hot ham
ha I love my mom's sweet ham ass that is
how do I stop thinking about my mom
throwing it back on a real one when my
mom grinds my ham bone so funny but no
now this is my this is my favorite a lot
where the [ __ ] did it my mom's got a
sweet ass
do I do dude this is quite possibly the
worst [ __ ] take a guy was dying I
mean your brain and eyes are conscious
wait wait wait sorry your brains and
eyes versus your conscience or one thing
but ass is ass oh come on and your 15
year old boner doesn't have a clue dude
ass is ass no it's not theirs ass and
then there's your mom's ass there are
two extremely different things there's
ass and there's mom and one is Shane
there's dad a dad has to
okay mom ass is shaped like a triangle
sometimes it's shaped nice yeah yeah
it's not sexual yeah how do I stop being
turned on by my mom's sweet triangle ass
ass is nice it's round it's it's it's
Hardy it's designed to turn you on you
know I'm saying yeah I was thinking
gives you imagine if your [ __ ]
therapist said that [ __ ] yeah okay
there's a long story like laying down
the code and I'm really afraid I'm
attracted to my mom Michael ass is ass
its ass when you throw let me throw up a
simple equation for your right real
quick okay ass equal sign ass underlined
you see that Michael ass equals ass now
what that mean to you what that mean it
means asses ass son okay all right your
mom's got a sweet [ __ ] ass and you
shouldn't feel ashamed throw a simple
equation free he's blocking the board so
there is nobody said writing it's the
white yeah plastic cap ass is ass
Michael look read can you read me can
you read me what I've written here on
the board um big big beautiful butt
cheeks equals sweet supple ask me means
that's Michael it means asses ass
let me take you through some examples
look at this ass right here whose ass do
you think this is tell me whose ass do
you think this is Michael go ahead that
that's your mom's ass okay why do you
believe my mom's ass she's got a sweet
ass there's no denying it
look at that ass meet Michael another
picture whose ass do you think this is
this look like a woman's asking you it's
James Charles it's the bit it's the
greatest ass in entertainment okay it's
the great ass because you know what ass
is ass ass transcends gender everything
its ass its ass god damn it and your
mother has some amazing but she's got
some great cheeks on her [ __ ] cut me
off a prime rib cut it at it Michael I
just I was like in hysterics
I just kept repeating as his ass no it's
not pass is ass the worst like drunk
uncle [ __ ] you could say Amen Uncle
Jimmy I'm scared I looked at mom's ass
and I'd like today brother I like it too
bad she's my sister she's my sister
I'd still [ __ ] hit that here's the
thing man she's my sister but her ass if
you put that on anybody I [ __ ] that
ass her ass oh it's a whole different
thing because Michael ass is ass yeah
and that ass could be on anything she's
my sister her ass is not my sister's ass
it's just an ass [ __ ] put that ass on
the back of a truck I'd [ __ ] that truck
you know what I mean it's a good ass I
was I was hysterical it's really good
ASSA is really good
[Music]